fux origin is related to Dutch German
and Swedish words for to strike and to
move back and forth huh legend has it
that [ __ ] was an acronym for fornicate
under consent of the king this has been
debunked [ __ ] the first known use of
[ __ ] was from a poem in about fourteen
seventy five it was written attacking
the Carmelite friars of the English town
Ely and translates to they are not in
heaven because they are [ __ ] the
wives of Ely
[ __ ] in the 1300s people said
swive instead of [ __ ] [ __ ] was
officially included in an italian
english dictionary in 1598 and was used
as a rude term for sex but didn't become
a swear word until the early to mid 19th
century what the [ __ ] [ __ ] is one of the
seven dirty words not allowed on
television as listed by comedian George
Carlin is famous 1972 monologue Carlin
was arrested several times after
performing the routine but it ended up
causing a landmark Supreme Court case on
obscenity and freedom of expression in
broadcasting you if a single [ __ ] is
uttered PG film rating becomes a pg-13
if more than one [ __ ] is given a pg-13
movie is bumped up to rated R the film
would the second-most [ __ ] in history
is the wolf of Wall Street with 569
bucks what's number one a documentary
called [ __ ] about the word [ __ ] with a
hundred fifty seven [ __ ] season 1
episode 4 of The Wire features a
four-minute scene where two detectives
only say the word [ __ ] bye mother bull
after season 1 AMC only loved Breaking
Bad to use the word [ __ ] uncensored once
per season leading to lengthy
discussions among the writers about
where [ __ ] was deployed best ah the
autodefense or frank acceptance of blame
refers to captain Cole hey ah so who
mistakenly landed an airplane in San
Francisco Bay in 1968 his defense was as
you Americans say I [ __ ] up oh [ __ ]
the quickest is sending off in a soccer
match was a red card given to Lee Todd
in 2000 just two seconds into the game
after the whistle blew and he muttered
[ __ ] me that was loud
but Marilyn Manson once wrote [ __ ]
across his face so paparazzi taking his
photos can't print them [ __ ] yeah
author Roald Dahl's second to last words
to his family were it's just that I will
miss you all so much his actual final
words after a nurse pricked him with a
needle were ow [ __ ] will